j'ai eu ça de l'artisanat
rse sacralisation du sénat iso 9001 iso
iso 26000 il faut prendre cette nuit
nous ferons rehaussé dans les pâturages
pour les siècles et des siècles
l'énorme à dos tous c'est à ça qu'on les
reconnaît
l'énorme personne ne les réclame tout le
monde leur pays
bientôt elles s'attaqueront aux états
dans les pays riches on croule sous les
normes c'est devenu une véritable
industrie alors en france en 2013
appelons ça comme ça en ouvert un
nouveau type de déchetterie le conseil
d'évaluation de la norme et le conseil
d'évaluation de la norme nous dit ceci
quand les temps de papier sont plus
longs que les temps de chantier un
constat s'impose il y aura bientôt plus
de gens à faire les normes et contrôles
et leur application qu'à bien faire les
choses sur le terrain
c'est pas sérieux et il poursuit
faut-il que notre société soit inquiète
pour être atteint d'une telle boulimie
normative d'une telle obésité d'une
telle incontinence d'une telle
hypertrophie faut-il que notre société
soit inquiète pourraient tomber dans un
tel intégrisme normatif ou faut-il que
ce soit l'engrenage de la normalisation
qui nous inquiète les peurs finalement
depuis que le mans fait société nos
peurs sont toujours les mêmes des
romains par exemple qui croulait sous
les normes de rome
les romains étaient fascinés comme nous
par le mythe ce vieux mythe vieux comme
le monde de la standardisation et bien
les romains comme nous avaient peur des
voleurs
les romains avaient peur aussi des
envahisseurs et puis les romains
craignait aussi surtout la révolte des
esclaves les gaulois eux les gaulois qui
faisait plutôt l'éloge de la différence
les gaulois comme nous avaient peur de
la fin du monde alors il ne craignait
pas que le niveau de la mer en tenons il
craignait que le ciel ne leur tombe sur
la tête
l'epr sont toujours les mêmes mais on ne
parlait pas des pièges de la
normalisation et peut-être des excès de
normes sur nos peurs si j'étais né chez
les romains je n'aurais pas vu que
j'aurais est éliminé si je vous parle
des normes que c'est que pour moi dès ma
naissance tout est allé de travers alors
sociaux orthopédique gouttière corset à
balen rééducation ma jeunesse n'a été
qu'une succession de redressement je
suis né dans un petit village un petit
village qui s'appelle la cage
imaginez la mer à perte de vue la grève
autour de mon village des champs avec
des petits maraîchers qui pratiquer
l'agriculture diversifiée je suis né
dans un atelier d'éducation populaire
qu'on appelait autrefois un bistrot qui
faisait épicerie tenue par ma mère et
j'ai grandi les pieds dans les copeaux
de l'atelier de mon père qui était
menuisier charpentier
je suis donc le produit du petit
commerce de proximité de l'artisanat en
voie de disparition
pour le moment mais ça peut changer et à
ma porte décidément entourée de hauts
murs imaginer une école de redressement
tenu par lé père missionnaire de
l'église catholique qui partait
redresser l'afrique avec les normes de
l'église catholique et revenez dans mon
village en bon colonisateurs blancs pour
redresser les délinquants évidemment
quand il débarquait chez ma mère ça
faisait un tel mélange de genres que
petit point j'avais l'impression d'être
né dans un théâtre au lieu
d'émancipation le théâtre mais
l'émancipation sais pas du tout ce qu'on
nous apprend des tout petits on nous
apprend l'obéissance l'obéissance et
l'excellence l'excellence et la division
puisque les meilleurs élimine les moins
bons et on doit trouver ça normal
l'énorme petit les normes sociales je
veux qu'on prenait son qu'on me les
explique à peu près de cette façon
alors mes parents étaient là bien sûr
pour me protéger et pour me corriger
attention si je ne finis pas droit
autrement pour les loups il y avait des
chasseurs pour les gendarmes y avait des
voleurs pour les malades des hôpitaux
pour les tordus du redressement
si j'avais d'excellentes notes à l'école
j'aurais dû travailler un bon métier si
j'étais sympa toute ma vie j'aurai plein
montant à l'enterrement
et si je désirerais prochain j'aurai une
place au paradis
je trouvais que ce destin collectif que
ces constructions collectives étaient
parfaitement d'organiser pour moi est
très rassurant ma foi mais j'ai grandi
j'ai ouvert les yeux et puis toujours le
même chemin
une grande surface est arrivé à côté de
chez moi
alors on a fermé le bistrot épicerie de
ma mère et on a ouvert une grande
déchetterie les normes
pendant un temps j'ai cru qu'elle
servait d'intérêt général parce que
c'est ce que j'avais appris que vous
avez repris je les crues et puis je me
suis mise en douter sérieusement dans
mon bureau où je travaillais comme
conseiller dans un service juridique et
je recevais des personnes en difficulté
les personnes en difficulté qui m'en
parlait le plus d'énormes c'étaient les
petits agriculteurs qui me disait ceci
j'entendais de discours j'entendais
madame marie on va pas pouvoir vous
payer
rendez vous compte on est à cinq ans de
la retraite on n'a pas voulu se mettent
aux normes on va pas s'endetter
le problème c'est qu'on a pu le rabot ci
qu'est ce qu'on va devenir
vous vous rendez bien compte quand même
que les gros vont bouffer tous les
petits les gros sont en train de bouffer
tous les petits et de l'autre côté
j'entendais madame marie on peut pas
vous payer fait patienter votre
direction
on a été obligés de s'endetter on n'a
pas le choix il a fallu s'agrandir pour
se mettre aux normes
vous voyez bien que les petits sont
amenés à disparaître de toute façon les
petits sont amenés à disparaître
je pensais pour la deuxième version je
m'éloignais un peu de la barbarie donc
je préférais choisir la fatalité qu'est
ce que j'y pouvais moi si les petits
étaient amenées à disparaître
et puis quand j'ai reconnu le nom de v
clients dans les avis de décès j'ai
compris que c'était pas du tout la
fatalité que la fatalité n'existe pas
que bien sûr la disparition de nos
petits paysans de nos petits commerçants
artisans c'est bien la conséquence de
nos erreurs de mauvais choix de nos
mauvais schéma c'est une bonne nouvelle
finalement ça veut quand même bien dire
qu'on peut tout changer pour arrêter
l'hémorragie
on peut changer de direction
on peut changer doit changer de voie
c'est ce que j'ai fait pendant mon
service juridique un sur ma demande et
même pu recevoir mes clients on allait
traiter leurs dossiers à distance
c'était mieux mon métier perdait tout
son sens alors je les quitter pour
emprunter une autre voie la voie du
technique
c'est dire si j'étais poursuivi dans les
normes parce que dans le technique tout
énorme
j'ai découvert forcément des normes très
utiles comme les normes de sécurité sur
les chantiers indiscutable
et puis d'autre de la modernité comme la
haute qualité environnementale vous
savez ce certificat de virginité ce
qu'on mange giresse véritable privilège
des pays riches de [ __ ] la planète
tout en ayant l'air d'être vertueux la
double flux par exemple la double
extraordinaire ce poumon extraordinaire
en plastique qui fait de respirer votre
maison transformée en bocal alors qu'ils
aspirent d'air polluées du dehors pour
l'amener à laterrière et qui expire
merville ci est la double flux imaginez
pour fabriquer une double flux
la somme d'énergie et pour la faire
tourner et n'oubliez pas de changer les
filtres attention hein sinon vous frôlez
catastrophe sanitaire et au bout de dix
ans la double flux déchetterie très
écologique la double flux
enfin j'en étais là du technique quand
un beau jour notre directeur nous avons
qu'on veut nous a convoqués pour nous
annoncer une grande nouvelle une très
grande nouvelle
alors nous allons nous lancer dans une
grande aventure tout en sauvant la
planète naturellement et nous allions
tous monter en compétences nos clients
allaient nous accorder plus de confiance
et la banque plus de crédit nous allions
nous convertir un certification en le
discours était tellement beau les mythes
religieux que nous on a trouvé ça beau
comme une prière
je vous jure qu'à cet instant dieu
n'était même plus une hypothèse
forcément c'est facile avec nous parce
que quand on nous parle d'esprit
d'équipé et puis deux victoires
collectives
on confond tout à l'heure en s'emballe
forcément on a tous été catho ou coco ou
scouts ou entraîneur joueur de foot
enfin quoi alors très vite très vite on
a tous confondus en fait on a confondu
le grand soir avec la terre promise et
les clés du paradis avec la victoire de
la coupe du monde et on s'est tous
emballés
alors d'abord premièrement parmi nous on
a désigné un contrôleur c'était normal
ensuite on a refait la déco des bureaux
très important les codes couleurs pour
la certification très important la
vitrine adecco alors c'est du botox mais
ça fait pro ensuite on nous a demandé
d'écrire tout ce qu'on savait faire
alors on a écrit tout ce qu'on savait
faire nos trucs de ficelle le combine
tous et puis ensuite bien sûr on a fait
tout ce qu'on avait écrit alors on a
fait tout ce qu'on avait écrit mais on
l'a fait un peu plus vite que d'habitude
pour descendre la procédure on a changé
de braquet
on a changé de régime nous avons acquis
de nouveaux automatismes et nous sommes
passés de la réflexion aux réflexes et
au bout d'un an
la tête sur le guidon
la veille du grand audit est arrivé
alors les boule dans la gorge et puis
des auréoles sous les bras parce que
pendant mon avis qu'un seul objectif
obtenir la meilleure note par bons
acquis
donc la veille quand même on a révisé la
procédure et le jour du grand audit est
arrivé alors bien sûr les pères
missionnaires de la certification sont
venus nous contrôler ils se sont
enfermés dans un bureau pendant
plusieurs heures
et puis son parti comme il était venu et
qu on a attendu on a attendu la bonne
note sur les 47 ans j'attendais ma bonne
note et bien sûr la bonne note est
tombée 18 sur 20 champagne a dit le
directeur
le plus beau jour de la vie de l'équipe
est-ce qu'on était content 18 sur 20 et
puis dit gist survint c'était génial ça
nous laisser encore une jolie petite
marge de progression pour les années
s'ils vont trop bien à ce qu'on était
content sauf qu'après vingt les jours
les semaines les mois les années se sont
succédé sans qu'on n'ait plus rien à
inventer parce que on nous demandait
plus notre avis et on en demander plus
je ne peux rien inventé car nous étions
payés pour exécuter mais plus pour
penser et finalement la montée en
compétence avait été simplement une
montée en hobby licence mais pas du tout
en qualifications alors quand on a
compris les limites de la normalisation
et c'est enfermement on peut se poser
une question quand même pour s'en sortir
on fait comment est-ce que
l'émancipation passerait pas par la
mauvaise note pour commencer c'est en
posant ces questions je me suis dit j'ai
inversé la vapeur maintenant les normes
c'est moi qui les poursuit alors se
multiplier les rencontres et puis j'ai
réceptionné des témoignages et puis dans
cette aventure et bien jour finalement
je me suis retrouvé chez moi tout seul
parce que mes enfants étaient partis
puis mon mari m'a aussi
et j'étais bourré de contradictions
parce que d'un autre d'un côté j'étais
toujours ce drôle d'oiseau de la baie et
de l'autre côté j'étais quand même un
bon soldat un sonore qui marchaient au
pas et je me suis dit si tu veux te
débarrasser quand même une bonne somme
de contradictions il est peut-être temps
que tu fais quelque chose quand tu vas
travers dans ma vie moi j'ai un truc
c'est une fille de bord de mer
alors je vais marcher dans la baie je
marche je marche avant j'arpente les
grèves de mon enfance en fait
et puis se passer un truc c'est qu'on
arrive au milieu je sais bien que je
suis plus qu'un point que je ne suis
plus rien qu'un petit point minuscule et
que finalement mes soucis au regard du
monde sont encore bien plus minuscule
que moi alors arrivés au milieu de la
baie je me suis dit bon écoute si tu
veux changer de direction postaux à une
question
mais alors une seule est la question qui
m'est venue c'est qu'est ce que tu as
préféré dans ta vie mais la réponse qui
m'est venue c'est la colo
mais ouais c'est vrai les colonies de
vacances moi j'adorais ça quand j'étais
petit j'allais en colo avec les soeurs
de la sainte famille c'était génial je
pourrai toujours pour entrer parce que
j'ai marqué mes copines les réfectoires
le dortoir tout ça je me suis battu
fasse quelque chose de sale a tenté d'en
milieu de la baie kolokolo collectif
tout seul dans sa grande maison habitat
collectif colo site ajoute 1 c à la fin
ça fait qu l'ops et du désordre de ces
du chaos j'en sais rien enfin repart
avec ça tu vas bien réussir à faire
quelque chose est sûre parti avec mon
rêve sous le bras et puis je suis là
lance y engager des travaux sauf que au
bout de plusieurs mois de travaux m'ont
voix 5
un ancien directeur de banque est venu
tambouriner à ma porte
c'est pas bientôt fini vacarme nez vous
transformez votre maison bordel quoi
j'ai fait comme ça oui oui mais oui en
bordel mais un joyeux bordel
il va y avoir des jeunes à venir dans la
rue je vais vivre avec des jeunes
le pauvre homme il est venu tout vert et
après il est passé au rouge curieux j'ai
tout entendu des jeunes dans la rue mon
aura plus de pouvoir se garer
et puis de toute façon les jeunes ça
fait du bruit les jeunes ça crie ça boit
ça fumait sa vomi ils vont tous vous
dégradez j'ai coupé le poste c'est très
efficace
puis d'abord les risques étaient moins
qui les prenait c'était ya huit ans une
trentaine de jeunes se sont passées chez
moi et je peux vous assurer qu'ils m'ont
considérablement changé depuis que j'ai
songé ce schéma alors j'ai fait le soin
de ne jamais affiché de règlement
forcément et de ne pas compter sur
l'autodiscipline comme le fait si bien
iso et la normalisation mais de compter
sur la confiance mutuelle et en guise de
contre à une bonne poignée de main ça
marche toujours très bien
je n'ai pas changé le monde j'ai juste
changé un petit peu la mentalité de mari
parce que les voisins sont contents et à
chaque rentrée il se demande qui va
arriver
et puis dans mon jardin au printemps
j'ai poussé des étudiants alors ma
propre expérience m'amène à me poser
cette question sur les normes sur la
normalisation finalement vivre ou
gouverner est-ce que c'est tout prévoir
tout cadré ou est-ce que c'est embrasser
imprévisible je pose la question
les romains par exemple les roma qui
croulait sous les normes de rome et qui
était forgé à l'obéissance était habitué
à se battre en ligne ils ont été vaincus
par les germains qui les ont attaqués
par surprise dans tous les coins n'ont
pas su faire face aux imprévus en 2001
quand les tours se sont effondrées
les survivants ont été en majorité
tous ceux qui ont désobéi aux ordres de
pas bougé alors qui que vous soyez
individus ou sociétés
si votre petite voix vous intime de
désobéir de bouger de faire un pas de
côté pour emprunter une route en lacets
n'hésitez pas faites le mais loin des
modèles des standards et des modes
d'emploi vos nouveaux schémas de grâce
inventé l'est merci